3 Be careful not to die aname
[Music] I
don't talk in the water I've been
hit by a single blow
dan
yeah yeah tee tan I thought I should get in my pocket
[Music]  ] It
's difficult to receive Brad's blow perfectly,
but if you don't have the prefecture from
the front, you can jump in front of me through the blow.
Buy
one
[Music]
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
ni
I'm here. After all, my muscles are disadvantageous to my sister
. What is the gate
? You said that you don't
use that technique anymore.  I
don't want to get involved, but now I have internal organs.
Oh,
I went there before. You can't believe this person.
I didn't
live well-I would have died if I hadn't had a holiday,
so I've decided to pray for my life because
I was worried that you died instantly
.
Don't tell me, I
don't even eat Mark dogs What do you say
[music]